hallo leute herzlich willkommen zu einem
neuen video heute für eben wie ein
satanisches ich ein sadistisches ritual
für die leute eigentlich wollten wir ein
ganz normales video aufnehmen das kommt
wahrscheinlich morgen aber dann ist der
ganze drehen ein bisschen eskaliert
nicht vorbei da studieren wenn jetzt
bist du das passiert wenn doch es sieht
so geil aus holz tisch legen
1 buchst
herzlich willkommen zum heutigen video
werden auf dem scheiß gelaber wir
stellen heute youtuber interesse nach
und das funktioniert folgendermaßen
hatte sprint noch irgendwas an einem das
funktioniert folgendermaßen
wir wissen wie sich der schmerz anfühlt
das schwöre ich habe immer an fingern
als blau geworden
ich hab dort aufgestellt was passt warum
sollte man seinen finger eine mausefalle
legen muss man aber leute wir sind bei
einer neuen folge
jetzt hat auch noch gewitter junges
eskaliert brennt plate neue vergessen
die alte frank nitsche leute es ist
verkrüppelt ist er denkt was jeweils ein
weg gebracht hat bis heute wieder leute
er wird gefeiert
schaffen wir 20.000 likes für die
nächste fußball challenge vielleicht
sogar mit steinbuch die scheiße guckt
einfach immer noch
alter ist dass man drei hoch ist so ein
halloween accessoire oder ein video
damit habe ich aber ist eine richtige
pause verkauft was auch wichtig wie man
mit finger und immer noch ist der wohl
richtig blau und hat irgendwie eine
woche als ob ich da rein halten
kinder erzählen
damals war es kein wiedersehen wollte
ich mit ihm auf dem platz
wir sehen ob ich mir das ding wirklich
quatsch oder nicht ich habe recht machen
leute
wir werden heute den heiligen gott der
lang wie das ist echt wohl die idee das
wirft mich abmelde
kaufen wir brauchen tropfen alter mit
richtig gebrandmarkt und konnte das ist
giftig wie wenig das kommando asterix
und kleopatra schmilzt die geschmolzen
cd tropfen dann auf dem kuscheltier
tropfen lässt alles nazis versteckt und
dann
wo wenn nicht nominieren wollen wissen
was ich meine
warum denn ja klar teams wer den mund zu
mund geben was sprüht schimmel run wird
ihn jemals benutzt niemals diese alten
rostigen shisha schläuche diese billigen
schlechte immer dabei sind macht sowas
auch gar keinen fall
lasst den jungen einfach mal leiden hier
es ist ein ritual hatte hallo leute
herzlich willkommen zu einem neuen video
heute für eben wie ein satanisches ein
sadistisches ritual für die junge stopp
stopp stopp sitzen als gegentrend auch
gerade das elektroauto mal guckt euch
mal an alter du musst jetzt im flug vom
trinken ich merke ich mal gar nichts was
ist das